welcome back to peers working on
sensible with Marianne Williamson is a
best-selling author a celebrity
spiritualist a confidant of Oprah
Winfrey and she has her way she'll also
be America's first female president when
many Democrats warning that Joe Biden is
simply too old to run again she wants to
outflank him from the left the more
youthful left you might think and
harness love to defeat Donald Trump and
I'm delighted to see you're here in
London in my studio great to see you
thank you thank you so much for having
me I want to play you a clip this is
President Biden last week uh ending a
speech about gun violence by completely
randomly saying this
it's the least consequential part of
this whole meeting for you I promise
all right God Save the Queen man
okay well two things
the queen died 10 months ago she's not
our Queen uh yes not your queen and and
our queen died 10 months ago this is the
latest thing involving President Biden
where he just said stuff which makes no
sense actually it's pretty inappropriate
to some people quite offensive he seems
to have forgotten our queen died last
year
um and it goes to his mental capability
it's a big issue I mean it can't be
ignored I don't think how do you feel
about this I you know I think it's for
the individual voter to decide it gets
personal and I don't want to be personal
about this I'm running against the
president on issues uh there are many
people in his Camp who would argue yes
he makes gas like this but when it comes
to his decision making on issues he's
just fine every individual has to decide
on that and I think it's kind of cheap
for me to go there
I mean it happens a lot
it happens a lot obviously I wouldn't be
running if I didn't think I'd make a
better president right
um I want to talk about a couple of
issues with you which are in the news
which you have quite strong views about
one I want to play you a clip this is
the British prime minister Rishi sunak
who was heard on a leaked video uh
talking about the big trans debate at
the moment
you may have noticed uh Ed Davey has
been very busy uh like me you were
simply seen that he was busy trying to
convince everybody that women clearly
had penises and I was reflecting you all
know I am a big fan of everybody
studying maths to at but it turns it
turns out that we need to focus on
biology
so this has become a big thing right
um along with the question what is a
woman there's now a big debate where
British political leaders have been
asked about whether a woman can have a
penis and they've given bearing answers
the British prime minister says no the
labor leader says 99 of women do not and
the liberal Democrat leader who he was
referencing there says clearly women can
have penises on on the face of it this
might seem a strange debate to be having
but what are the answers I mean you're a
presidential candidate well in the
United States I think we are obviously
going through a cultural transformation
people are getting more comfortable with
the notion of gender fluidity non-binary
sexuality for me it's an issue of
Freedom people get to be whoever they
want to be do whatever they want to do
if it doesn't hurt anyone else to me we
have to follow a North star in our
society that North Star is the idea that
all people are created equal if you talk
to me about a trans-american the part
that matters to me is the word American
and so but what is a woman to you
listen it's whatever at this point in in
somebody's culture in an American
culture certainly kind of whatever
anyone says that it is
it absolutely can if people hurts people
but if anyone could put their hand up
and say they're a woman we have a
situation we had recently where the
leader of the Scottish of Scotland
Nicholas sturgeon of the Scottish
national party she had to resign after
putting a biological male rapist into a
woman's prison so there is obviously
damage there from self-identity isn't it
well certainly the yeah but I think the
issue there was rapists not the issue of
the sexual uh what is the fact she felt
that she felt that this male rape is to
identified as a woman at his trial yeah
that would be horrible right simply to
get into a woman's prison that's wrong
right well yes but then that's that's
once you're talking about something like
rape then obviously it becomes relevant
it does it's not relevant what about
sport well on Sports I do think we need
to protect girls who were born as girls
if they are in a situation where
somebody obviously because of the size
of their of their muscles and of their
body gives them enough that's all
biological names well yes that's sort of
my point so you would stop well hang on
just to clarify that you would stop
biological males competing against
biological females unless can be proven
there are some situations where somebody
let's say that one is a man but they're
a small man right and it can be proven
through hormone testing through muscle
testing and so forth that there is no
biological Advantage but you know the
other day I spoke at Cambridge
University and I noticed when I went
into the area where the bathrooms were
that it said use whatever bathroom
you're more comfortable with and I
thought oh my God it could be that easy
so I think everybody needs to lighten up
on this issue because it's funny it's
hard to lighten up if you are say a
female Olympic Athlete and you're losing
out on your place well that's because
the biological male is six foot three
inches and built like an outhouse
decides to take your slot by saying hey
I'm a woman which goes back to your
initial thing that you should all be
what you want to be well sure I want to
be you know I want to be a movie star
but I'm not there's a reality check
if you're talking about specific
instances such as Sports such as where
somebody goes in prison Etc then
obviously these become issues that have
to be deciding points but there is
another world out there which it's not
hurting anybody it just has to do with
somebody's desire to identify a certain
way the area where we need to culturally
open our mind to the idea of fluidity in
gender and so forth and both can be true
at the same time well I'm not sure it
can because I don't think you can have
Limitless self-identity without it
infringing particularly on women's
rights to equality and fairness that's
the problem with it and that's why it
sounds great to say of course you can
but then you end up with that ridiculous
woman Rachel dolezel who decides to
identify as black
well if you have Limitless self-identity
why can't you
you know I think that somehow we have to
find that balance in ourselves as well
as ourselves as a lawmaker who wants to
be the first female president of the
United States
what's the balance because you either
allow it or you don't no I disagree with
you as president I think my uh my
responsibility is to the notion of all
people created equal I as president
quite the opposite of what you just said
as president hey I want the whole notion
of of my presidency would be please be
who you want to be do what you want to
do spread your wings and soar if you get
to the point where you're infringing on
the rights of other people you're going
to have a hard time how would you feel
if a uh if a man decided to a male
politician decided to suddenly identify
as female and became the first woman
president of the United States I'd be
like damn but that
that would have just been down you'd be
like what I don't think he'd be
horrified but that doesn't mean I think
it would be illegal or that it's I
didn't say it'd be illegal that's the
whole point the whole point uh Madam
would be president is it it's perfectly
legal I mean well that's my it's just
wrong I don't even think it's wrong it's
just we I think we'd all uh down a few
glasses of wine that night we wouldn't
be real happy about it Usain Bolt wants
to run as a woman in the Olympic 100
meters you're going to allow it no
that's that I I believe that this thing
was Sports we must protect those who who
you know when you see these girls who
were born as girls and they have worked
so hard you know obviously and I think
most people see that quickly about
reparations yes we've had lots of
debates on the show about this whole
issue I I have to admit I come from a
position I don't see why people today
should be compensated for sins against
their ancestors some cases centuries ago
explain to me why I'm wrong because it's
not just about you it's about the
responsibility that you have as a
citizen to the fate of your country and
whether you are an individual or a
nation you're not going to have the
future you want if you don't clean up
the past you know so should I okay but
on that then should I be claiming money
back as someone in Britain from the
Italians for what the Romans did from
the Normans for what they did from the
Vikings from the for their forebears now
should I be claiming reparations from
all of them and if not what's the
difference I'll tell you what the
difference is there is no way that a
modern Brit is being economically
disadvantaged by something that the that
the Vikings did well I think it's been a
long long yeah no there might be people
in the middle of Britain no who are
still suffering the Opportunity
Financial injury of what the Romans did
to their families let me answer your
question it is very obvious that there
has been intergenerational hardship
financially the gap between blacks and
whites that is so egregious in America
today is a legacy not only of slavery
not only 250 almost 250 Years of Slavery
but also of almost a hundred years since
then of institutionalized suppression of
black people this is 300. do we stop
feeling guilty about the past after
we've paid our debt or paying for the
party there's a difference here's my
body it never stops once you once you
uncork that bottle you end up never
stopping you need to let me talk there's
a difference between blame and
responsibility I don't feel I need to
feel guilty my parents came from Russia
and Poland my grandparents so it's not
about my grandparents it's not about my
feeling guilty it is about my feeling
responsible for for the well-being of my
nation Germany paid over 89 billion
dollars to Jewish organizations after
World War and I think that that
Financial remuneration has had a lot to
do with not only the financial but even
more importantly the psychological and
emotional healing between Germany and
the Jews of Europe and this is a healing
that we have not had that war was over
in
1945. Iris was over in 1865 and we still
take this time and we pass it
Generations you make a good point I need
a one-word answer to this question to
wrap things okay should Donald Trump if
he gets convicted of a federal crime and
actually goes to prison the Constitution
says he can still be president of the
United States should he be allowed to be
it's not about the laws the law would it
be disappointing would it be awful for
the country yes but if it's legal it's
legal Mary great to see you thank you
great to have you in London